you can't tell the story of the American
jury without telling the story of
America it starts with the Declaration
of Independence in which we as a legal
matter define ourselves as an
independent people and assert our
sovereignty as a people that that is the
Declaration of Independence we don't get
to the jury until we get to the
Constitution of the state in the
constitution of the state the jury is
the method that we the people adopted as
our strategy for controlling the state
the most fundamental relationship
between citizen and state was defined by
the jury the jury took two forms the
core idea is one of justice and the core
idea of justice is fair trial and a fair
trial has three parts a fair charge a
fair opportunity to defend and a fair
verdict all right now the jury is the
linchpin of fair trial first with
respect to the charge the grand jury the
idea was we the people should control
what charge can be brought against a
person that can put him in such jeopardy
before a jury of his peers that they
could take his freedom away that's the
grand jury and then the opportunity to
defend that becomes cross-examination
the high point of the trial the actual
testing of the witnesses who have made
the charge and then the verdict and
that's the Pettit jury
the idea of 12 coming to a unanimous
verdict and that's the idea of the jury
and the thought is that if the state
couldn't take a man's freedom away
unless he had a fair trial the jury was
the bulwark of freedom that's the story
of the journey